look at this man you guys getting the
same man oh dude I am a man dude oh I'm
the man he's gonna tell me I'm a man I'm
a man all right well I'm gonna be a
snail
what kind of head we got this one looks
just so worried I'm gonna go with this
one just pissed she looks terribly
worried and I think that's the only
appropriate response to this situation
oh I can I can I have clothes
there we go pants there we go yeah I got
some pants I'm ready
who's ready yeah I'm ready how do we
ready up
I'm ready how do we do that wait do you
have to set it to private co-op good
good that won't yeah let wait left my
scripted Oh mouse sensitivity oh wait
where are you guys more connected you
guys should be loading in I think I'm in
a room I'm in a room I'm in a room by
myself I'm in a room by myself
oh is it trying to fill the lobby yeah
because you didn't put private game you
idiot in my open doors were you [ __ ]
wait where are you I can't see one of
you just opened the door to the room I'm
in but we're invisible until we all
spawn in oh okay starting so you guys I
made a private all nice and good yeah
you're so talented I'm in a red room we
get to be friends yet what are you
pointing that way titties you are a
sexist [ __ ] the first thing you
say out of your words to me is look at
those titties what a piece of [ __ ] you
are
[Music]
okay well it's very rude you're
obviously objectifying me this is such
garbage behavior look at the worst Keanu
Reeves impersonator that's why are you
white Noren jatt no wait hang on shut up
wait he's got a point you are the worst
Keanu Reeves impersonator I've ever seen
no it's me Keanu Reeves catch my new
movie Jon week five okay sounds good I
hope there's five down like movies
alright guys so you guys remember the
deal right marker you look a thousand I
remember the deal yeah I'm a thousand
feet tall what does it matter you're
like wait I'm like at shoulder height
with my POV are
told to you I know no you seem like a
shrimpy little baby you guys are about
to your place to be weighed and I look
like I'm in your nipples on mine yeah
I'm at like nip level I don't your stop
talking about my nipples Oh mark you got
boob physics do I will stop looking at
them no I'm not gonna look anyway I'm
not gonna look I want to look do it I
don't want to look no no but you have a
stain in your crotch mark yeah there's a
stain in there jump again win look at
that you see that you see I know I see
it I see it I see no don't you dare
sorry that was a mistake
that was a mistake what did you do I'm
getting the boot [ __ ] you it's my
[ __ ] that's my adidas I'm gonna open
the door
I opened the door alright
oh there's a skinner there's a skill
there's a skeleton but it's got a boot
Bob what is extra food why is there
water well this room is safe okay I
switched I took his boot
I got cool boots now why you just got an
extra boot it's just so that we can
throw seams Dave the room lights up
clear it's safe how do you know I hear
jingling on the other side of this room
this room's gonna be like a little point
good but you that's death that's what
death looks like I mean it doesn't look
like health no there's chains on it what
are the chains do in this universe you
die if you get hit it moderately hard
with a chain single door can we do the
jingle drawing although I don't like
what's on the other side that's okay
what do we throw shoe shoe all right
yeah no let him do it you go in wait'll
see what happens fine
Wow wait I thought that was gonna hit
you like my mark okay come in here oh
god how do I run how do I run how do I
run you shift is like walk you you're at
full speed already okay these chests
like this I already got a bandage I
already got a bandage man oh look so
dumb yeah but mine's cool they're
they're they're bandage on the ground
wait
bandage on the bread wait wait Bob just
took it Bob took it you idiot but it's
right there yeah that's the thing grab
it yeah you spend your time getting that
way then we'll do will do they will do
the rest
whoa ghost oh I saw that huh I got this
one boys I got all right okay cool
B do you totally safe into it
everything's cool so the red means we
can't go that way that's the border I
know what it mean we played this game
before
well the first one hey wait do you need
me bandage just angry yeah I used one
I'm okay you can hang on to it in case
we uh get hurt you know I wasn't really
gonna give you any but yeah I figured
those are my bandages Bob you need to
give those what the hell its inception
top oh no you're staying there is this
beyblades room I don't understand I
think that room is safe you just can't
touch the corners or the thing in the
middle okay this room is now safe so I'm
going to go this way to check out this
other room why would you why aren't we
sticking together there's a boot over
here and I don't need a boot oh there's
no their shoe in here I got another shoe
in here yeah I got a lot of shoes that's
pretty cool how you guys doing over
there there's a hole in this one
well there's a hole found the edges into
a new floor oh this is yes hey guys
don't look over here oh don't look don't
look going yeah oh yeah did you know
what are you talking about I like the
sound of this door do you hear this do
you hear how promising that is I'm ready
oh I think we should go in guys I think
this is our room I'm steaming over here
alright so what does that do look what
it is what it's fun okay that room is
just awful in every way it's the worst
okay this is a death room okay that's
baby you were so close to that I like
Mark Twain all books oh don't look at
the ceiling in there that's not so good
wait you that's been in other rooms -
you've only just noticed that no I
didn't know yes yes no no you're going a
weird way I don't know why you're going
that way with it took my picture wait
where are you looking for a wait why are
you over there ask for you okay Bob it's
you and me is in this room safe now no
yeah safe coming back do you miss me
no who are you go away Serena alright
soup oh well that it's fine it's fine
don't worry don't worry
well I'm gonna trust you implicitly oh
mama I
guys I don't like I don't like that room
stand right behind you oh is this the
exit no maybe that's it it is totally
the exit yeah bye-bye wait wait third
floors third who we graduated together
yeah what who ever go away Bob okay do
you hear a weird noise I do okay we're
going left I'm here I'm with you it's a
present no I want the present I don't
trust that at all how do you present no
I do not
God told you ah well are you alive I'm
alive where does this go guys where does
this go Oh guys it's not a secret exit
mark Koehn oh you can't
no it's oh hell yeah look at that I like
standing over the abyss I don't like
standing over the abyss at all keyonna
which way are we supposed to go left
what who's left my life your left this
one a little bit too inebriated three
choosing you have multiple different oh
yeah like the thing you want to be doing
well is it fine otherwise I'm sure none
of these will crumble if you try and
jump on them they're fine find out don't
get my key on oh I'm just gonna leave
this door closed behind you it's fine
John week three in theaters now okay
it's working it's working that's
impressive
oh you know it's a death room it's not a
death water and spikes all over the
floor and no place to stand
fine try it it's all about I'm going for
Bobby I keep hoping the next time we
open the door waves
on the other side that's the way to go
good work that's the way to go all right
we're clear what's gonna body block wait
here
yeah let's say hey listen we don't need
your kind come on an uncomfortable
amount yeah why did you try to jump you
idiot yeah I feel like it was really
obvious what was gonna happen in that
situation yeah I feel like that was
entirely your fault
all right Bob now it's down to you and
me like it always was yeah Keanu I'm
alive and I have a new shoe calculated
we knew that was gonna happen
upper body posture is very keen on OS I
see these alligators in there hop the
[ __ ] in bro can you jump on their heads
can you jump on their head oh I hope so
wait hold your shoes don't you are you
real John Waker Six coming to theaters
next fall yeah okay Lord man they didn't
even [ __ ] wasted their energy
animating that they were just like
alligators in the water if you alligator
sausage in the sky
happened in my body you died okay
disintegrated it was very impressive
like you really wasted your second
chance at life well I love you guys my
shoes yeah okay I had to do something
for science wait I don't think you
should be as easily a peer pressured
into doing things as you are I figure it
was my second chance at life I might as
well use it for alligators I don't know
the logically follows there hey my shoe
got buried in the books
oh there's crispers yeah I saw I saw
okay I got to get over there don't know
man I was looking out for me
first graspers the laser in the thing
don't close doors in there there's a
ghost there's a ghost here is a ghost
guy huh good how you wellness oh good so
we have to go back to Maitreya yeah yeah
yeah you know it's fine I'm going I'm
going
the gravity's are very grabby grabbers
are Junior buying okay I hear something
in here is it me am i back alive
books just just some just some spiked
walls that's fine and a skull scaling
which is totally normal
yeah that seemed it's cool I'm just
gonna keep following mark I trust you I
am so brave so what is I think you might
be right that that window 91 you back up
back up back up back up I didn't have it
that's fine it's not that bad my shoe my
shoe just oh wow that's you [ __ ] gone
alright well lost my shoes I got the
shoes I got the shoes how's it going
shoes in there shooting there yeah okay
so I think that that's gonna be a wind
tunnel and it's gonna try to push you
into the spikes in the corner so avoid
being directly in front of the fan
blades like right now you've been going
around I do I wish I had the shoes all
right do Bob wait order the odds there's
a Shuba cactus okay you guys are totally
fine totally fine totally fine you think
I would throw my pants at some point you
could use that bandage I could dude I
haven't gotten hit once oh hi mark I
think I know a place where you might be
able to get hit I have balls
Oh oh I remember that room we already
learned that lesson yes we gotta go in
here no just so you know guys we press
em you can right-click on them
I don't care what you're saying right
now I'm easy I'm busy I'm busy
Oh
Oh God yes Bob yes what could it be
what's the urgency in there mark oh who
got shot all right I'm coming oh no wait
no I need my chute
I don't know what this is no this way
this way this way I found it you found
the thing I don't like it oh my god
thanks for saving me mark keanu floor
thing this time you're just [ __ ]
hanging out I'll just see this is my pod
man nice to be on you sick dodges in my
movie John wick 17 I really need a
bandage know what happens oh yeah I need
a bandage too
I need it more we are we going in the
dangles are we doing something you guys
do whatever you want
oh hi oh she's a goner
that's you guess that she's a goner oh
that's not good if you don't believe I'm
going for it let's choose mine all right
definitely watching this I grab the arms
grab the jus you didn't get to shoot
well
all right you got the shoe whoo I'm here
for the show we're good I got the shoe
don't close don't close don't close okay
shoot oh it's just a grabby arm this one
sounds cool I wanna see what's in here
another shoe I'm shoeless it's a shoe in
here Keanu if you go if you can dodge
the lasers no swinging
what a save [ __ ] Keano clutching up oh
I don't have any more shoes you got
shoes I got you
it didn't sell far enough I think I'll
try by walking in hell is this you right
here for you bud yeah I got a guy don't
worry I got I got we should protect you
keep moving for I'm gonna check that one
on the other side just to make sure the
exits not like in the corner over there
you keep moving forward he says so
innocently stop it this one's cool
I find the water unsettling I find the
electric sounds on the other side of
this room unsettling
that is bad oh that one's familiar I
like that room configuration yeah I'll
go right you go left oh this one has a
big happy sound coming out of it Oh
[Applause]
Oh laughs the wood lost the whole foot
and arms the night my foot and arm
lopped off yeah I see that yeah we were
so close maybe
[Music]
you